what are you fine I found a bone Nick
and I thought why do we go to cafe
across the street huh
we had no idea what we would find an
iPhone yeah screens broken as soon as it
is we went into the cafe who will call
when will they call sure enough I get a
call about ten minutes later from a
young man named Ralph
in local news New York man arrives in
California and drops his phone on the
side of the street apparently it's on
his way over for a back-alley pickup I
get a call another five minutes later
I'm entering the cafe are you here I
said yes I turn around I give his phone
back I said I'm sorry it looks like it's
been smashed to pieces but it still
works this is my father's last $10 made
with this money you'd never know hunger
and you never know a lost phone I'm
going to put it in the hambone jar today
is a very very special day the icon and
the banner for the salmon eco Channel
well they're a little outdated for a
long time we've plotted we've thought
we've considered how to make a better
banner and today is the day where we
actually execute on our evil plan we
want to come up with a banner that
actually represents what the Sam and
Nico channel is today Sam is sort of the
ringleader when it comes to design for
the corridor company took over annual
look over here now he hasn't really
explained what he wanted to shoot so I'm
interested to see how frustrated Sam
good will represent ideas that he
doesn't like hordes of everybody but me
and Sam on one side with like swords and
sent myself an other side of like battle
axes or maybe a arse to be great we're
always fighting here usually it's that
thick so let me tell Matt to make videos
out of it this isn't how you want to be
presented on
in that two years ago that was insane
trademark Jake smile like the one I see
every morning here for business
negative on American winter ball cake
you have to get it
what's next American but you gotta get
the profiles on any planet
this is Jake's brilliant idea just like
God and sticking out from space and
within it as a small solar system of us
all curled in ball form orbiting our
logo so today Sam walks in randomly with
a huge box of mug they don't get knocked
over there's a suction cup on them Wow
having a maje of that wouldn't fall over
I could be useful to it we won't know if
he's really were so until we test them
out and see if they can withstand our
collective stupidity
the constantly nerf war is going around
in this office can section withstand a
nerf gun
let's go closer pass the nerve test so
the next test is the blood test you
always have that co-worker who kind of
leaned back on your desk and sometimes
they don't know there's a cup they're
pretty good yeah that intros wrong it
works it works let's try it again
oh well I think the obvious next test
would be the earthquake test let's go to
a magnitude three then overall the
Mighty Muggs it can withstand the
average Joshua oh here and there we did
three tests and only passed one of them
one a half the veterans I'm going to
have to give it one and a half a cup Cup
point mug starts today ladies and
gentlemen you've done it what are you
talking about
first I'm going to unveil the new
channel icon alright for the grand
unveiling the new channel are you ready
here
if it's inverted a brilliant mind like
myself to come up with a side that's my
idea just invert it I don't know okay
anyway sincerely congratulations
there you go congratulations I hope that
we don't take as long to do things in
the future now second drum roll actual
channel yes boy it's live right now
anyone cares how I came up with a genius
idea it takes the colors and switch them
really I took our kid for he though yeah
I think if no one will ever thought of
put a groundbreaking idea welcome to
space station
we've got Electric skateboards we've got
one wheels and slightly better at one
Wilson Ren just believe it and believe
it and I will concede your skill claim
if you can do a pop shuvit on a one
wheel
like an ex professional snowboarder I
think I can kill everyone in a single
building in a single night oh I'm on the
knife with no boy this holiday come on
brother let me talk to you holiday if
you want hey thanks for the interview so
what what was your strategy going into
the game I'm worried I'm number one